تحالف الضروره قد يكون هذا هو الوصف
الاقرب للتكتل السياسي الذي شكلته سته من
احزاب المعارضه التركيه لخوض الانتخابات
الرئاسيه وحمل اسم تحالف الشعب فباستثناء
الخصومه الشديده مع الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان وحزبه فان ثمه تباينات فكريه
وسياسيه وايدولوجيه بين اضلاع التحالف
الطاولات السداسيه كما بات يعرف يتكون
تحالف الشعب من حزب الشعب الجمهوري اكبر
احزاب المعارضه واقدم الاحزاب التركيه ومن
يقدم نفسه وصيا للارث العلماني لمؤسس
تركيا الحديثه مصطفى كمال اتاتورك يراس
الحزباء كمال كليتش دار اوغلو الذي اصبح
ايضا مرشحه تحالف الشعب لخوض انتخابات
الرئاسه الحزب الجيد حزب وسطي قومي اسسته
وما زالت تتراسه ميرال اكشينار
السابقه في حزب الحركات القوميه حزب
السعاده حزب محافظ خرج من رحم حزب الرفاه
المنحل الذي كان يراسه الابا الروحي
للتيار الاسلامي في تركيا نجم الدين
اربكان ويراس الحزب حاليا تمل كرمولا
اوغلو الحزب الديمقراطي وهو حزب قومي وسطي
يراسه جولتك اما الضلعان الاخيران في
الطاوله السداسيه فهما حزبان جديدان
يراسهما رفيقان سابقان لاردوغان ومن كان
قبل سنوات قليله من قيادات الصف الاول في
حزب العداله والتنميه قبل ان يتحولا الى
خصمين له في هذه الانتخابات وهما حزب
المستقبل برئاسه رئيس الوزراء السابق احمد
داود اوغلو وحزب الديمقراطيه والتقدم
برئاسه وزير الخارجيه السابق علي بابا جان
ورغم ان تحال الشعب اطلق رسميا في فبراير
2022 فانه لم يتمكن من الاتفاق على اسم
المرشح لخوض رئاسه الا في السادس من مارس
الماضي وذلك بعد مخاض طويل وشد وجذب تخلله
انسحاب قصير لرئيسه الحزب الجيد ميرال
اكشنار من التحالف لرفضها خيار ترشيح
كليتشار اوغلو وتفضيلها لرئيس بلديه
اسطنبول الكبرى اكرم امام اوغلو او رئيس
بلديه انقره الكبرى منصور هواش التحدي
الاخر الذي قد يواجه تحالف الشعب في
مساعيه لجذب الناخبين يكمن في التصورات
التي قدمها لشكل الحكم في حال الفوز
بالانتخابات صحيح ان بيان الطاوله
السداسيه اشار الى ان المرشح الرئاسي
سيعين رؤساء الاحزاب الخمسه نوابا له لكن
شكل العلاقه معهم لاحقا ما يزال ضبابيا
لاسيما في ظل تصريحات احمد داوود اوغلو
بان رئيس ان تكون له صلاحيه اتخاذ قرارات
سياسيه فرديه او تعيين شخصيات في مناصب
سياديه دون العوده للطاوله وهذا امر يخيم
عليه الغموض خصوصا ان التحالف يريد العوده
لنظام البرلماني الذي يقلص صلاحيات الرئيس
لصالح عوده منصب رئيس الوزراء فضلا على ان
التحالف وضمن تسويه الاتفاق
علىهد الاخير بتعيين رئيسي بلديتي اسطنبول
وانقره مساعدين له دون الخوض في طبيعه
دورهما او صلاحياتهما